Today we're going to be looking at
Perplexica which is a free alternative
to Perplexity. Now this Publexi is is a
a powerful research tool but you can
basically use Publexica in a similar
way. It's a privy focused AI answering
engine um that runs locally. It can also
combine knowledge with local LMS and
it's pretty easy to set up. So the way
that I set it up was I literally just
gave it the GitHub link to Claude Code
and then Claude Code set it for me and
got it running locally. So we'll pull
that up and we'll have a look at how
perplexi works, how powerful it is,
whether it's worth using it or whether
it's worth sticking to perlexi.
>> So as you can see, this is what it looks
like. So now you can add connections. So
for example here, we could connect this
to Gemini or Lama. So with a llama, you
can actually run this locally with local
LMS, which is pretty awesome. You can
also connect this to Gemini,
Transformers, Grock, um, Anthropic, LM
Studio, which is another way to run LMS
locally as well. So, the way that I'm
going to run it is with Gemini today.
I'm just going to grab an API key. If
you don't want to pay for API keys, then
you could just use O Lama and run your
own AI locally instead. So, we're going
to grab an API key over here. I'm going
to create a new one inside AI Studio.
And then we can get started on this. And
I'll delete my API key after the show.
So, I'm just going to copy that. Then,
we'll go over to Plexio over here. We'll
paste that in. Call this Gemini as you
can see. And then we can plug that in.
And then over here, you can select which
chat models you want to enable and which
ones you want to remove. Now the other
cool thing here is you can actually if
you're using Gemini you can actually
load in Nano Banana and Nano Banana 2.
Why is that important? It means that you
can generate images for example which is
pretty awesome too. Um so that in your
results not only do you get textbased
results but you could also for example
add Gemini Nana Banana for generating
images too. Then from here you select
your embedding model and um whatever you
want as well. So you could use Gemini
for embedding I think and you could use
Gemini um 2.5 flash or you know 3.1
flash light that just came out as well
over here and then finish. Right. So
we're just going to test this out and
see how it performs. Right. So we've got
this set up here and then we'll see.
We'll just check if it's working. Yes.
So you can see it's working straight
away. It really does look like Plexi.
It's crazy. If you look at Plexi, this
is what Perplexi looks like. And then if
we go back, this is Perplexica, right?
They look very, very similar and they
seem to work in similar ways. Now one
thing that I would say is way better on
perplexity by a mile is that obviously
you can use computer right and if you're
not familiar with computer it's
basically like perplexity's answer to
open core but I would say it's even
better even more autonomous and you get
access to more AI models right so for
example you see we created this app
directly with Plexi computer using one
prompt um and it just works straight
away right so if you want access to
computer obviously you're not going to
get that on Plexica but if you want like
something that's just like basic local
uh free AI search engine then you can
use this and obviously it comes up with
images comes up with videos it's
connected to the web it can do whatever
you want right it seems to be pretty
fast as well because it's using
flashlight to respond and then you can
actually switch in this settings here
between speed balanced and quality right
and then you can also attach files you
can change the settings you can enable
web search academic search and social
search as well which is pretty cool so
you can actually search across socials
as well as academic resources and then
over here for example we say, okay, um,
what is open call claw? Let's see if
that works.
And we'll just make sure it's connected
to the web when it's coming back. So, it
seems to be able to search the web
pretty nicely. Again, this is a locally
hosted AI that's free, right? And it's
open source, too. And then it's it's
found like 71 sources, including the
official website of OpenClaw as well.
So, if we share this out, um, you can
see this actually found OpenClaw's
official website. So, it can connect to
the web. It is pretty fast as well to
respond. I think it's still searching
and replying for answers, but yeah,
that's basically how it works and it
seems to work pretty nice. The UI is
super nice and simple as well. You can
always go to the discover section here
as well if you want to see what other
people are doing or if you want to learn
new stuff like it pulls in all the
latest news over here, which is pretty
cool. And you can switch between
categories, so you can kind of use it as
a news source as well. And then inside
the library here, you can see your
previous history. So you can always
delete your chats. And then inside the
settings section here, you can add like
more preferences or you can add
personalization. You could actually add
system instructions. So here you could
tell it how to behave or ideas to come
back with or the tone of voice you
actually want or the actual personality.
You can change the models and add more
models inside this section too. And then
you can search for stuff as well, right?
And you can see here it's locally
connected which is pretty cool. And then
if we go back to home here and we add a
new chat, I think it should be able to
generate images. So I'm just going to
check
and see if it can generate this. So, it
does seem to struggle with generating
images even though it's connected to
Nana Banana. You can also play out the
sound as well over here. I think that
I'll be using Gemini Voice to play back.
But yeah, it's pretty cool. And then
inside the library, you can see okay um
what we come back with, what the
details, etc. Right. And you can
actually share um with Markdown or PDF
any results you get. So, if you do some
research, you can download it as a PDF
or you can share it in Markdown with
other people, which is pretty simple and
easy. So, it's a pretty cool tool,
pretty easy to set up. Um, I would say
at this point, if you want something
super lightweight and easy to set up,
Perplexer is pretty cool. Otherwise, I
would probably still stick with Perplexi
just for its computer usage and computer
on Plexi is amazing. And then the other
thing I would say here is like I would
look into setting something up like
OpenClaw because OpenClaw can do all of
this plus much more. Um, and if you're
not technical, if you don't know how to
set up openclaw, then you could always
run with something else. Like for
example, you could go with kilo claw,
which you can set up and host for free
online. It's pretty simple and easy. So
what just to recap, what is perplexica?
Perlex is a free open source AI search
engine. Think of it like this. Google
finds websites. Perplexica finds
websites and reads them for you and
gives you a simple answer with sources.
It's basically an open- source version
of Plexi, except with Plexica, it's free
forever. You can install it on your own
computer or server. Nobody sees your
searches. Um, and nobody gets access to
your data or anything like that, right?
It's built on the idea that AI and large
language models should be easy for
everyone to use. How does it work? Well,
you type a question, it sends your
question to a private search engine. The
system answers it. You get the search
results back and then it uses AI to read
all the results and the AI writes you a
clear, simple answer. Why would you
care? Well, you get privacy. It's free.
You get cited sources. It works with any
AI. You always get fresh results cuz
it's based on the web. And then it's
self-hosted as well. and the six
different focus modes. This is pretty
cool as well. So you get access to all
mode, academic search, YouTube search,
Reddit search, wolf alpha, and writing
assist as well. And then to install it,
the easiest way that I found is just
give the GitHub link to claw code to set
up. Otherwise, you can use docker or you
could use without docker as well. But I
think the easiest is just like give it
to openclaw or to claw code and say set
this up for me. And that'll be way
faster and easier. And that's basically
how it works. So thanks very much for
watching. If you want to get all the
video notes from today and daily new
guides on AI automation, you can get
that inside the AI profit boarding link
in the comments description or feel free
to go to the AI profitboarding.com. This
is my AI automation community that helps
you save time uh grow and scale with AI
automation. Inside the community, we
have 2,600 members. So, you can get
help, you can get support, you can ask
questions, etc. You can connect with
cool people, share your wins. You can
also get a daily accountability group
where you can stay laser focused on what
you want to achieve and see what other
people working on too. I do a weekly
update inside there. So I condense 60
hours of my research into one weekly
update so that you know exactly what to
focus on and what you can ignore so that
you save a lot of time. And then also
inside the calendar you get weekly video
coaching calls so you can ask questions,
get help, get support whenever you need
it. Additionally inside the map you can
meet local people in your area and then
inside the classroom here you can for
example go from beginner to expert with
AI automation and learn how to build
your first AI agent in under five
minutes. You can also for example get my
best playbooks on how to automate X
newsletters, shorts, AI avatar videos,
etc. Inside the SOP updates here, you
can get a full 6-hour course on Open
Claw plus another 3-hour course right
here. We also compare the new
automations come out. So today, for
example, I released guides on Kilocclaw,
Plexiga, Star Office UI, Plexi Skills,
Notebook LM updates, etc. Even the new
Claude code schedule task update we've
created a video on and that only came
out a few hours ago. And we create video
tutorials plus step-by-step guides and
plans as you can see right here for
everything that comes out. And we date
it so that you know, okay, here are the
new updates that came out today. Here
are the guides. Here are the video
tutorials so you never lose track again.
Additionally, inside here, you can learn
how to get more clients with the agency
course. You can watch about the coaching
course and and watch my videos of the
coaching course right here. You can
learn how to rank number one with AI
SEO. And then you can also learn how to
grow a YouTube channel based on what's
working for me. Now, some people might
be saying, okay, but you know, how are
people are people getting results with
this? Does it work? Etc. So, we've
actually got at this point 134 pages of
people getting wins with the AR profit
boarding, right? So, you can see all
these testimonials, all these people
sharing their wins, the progress they've
achieved, and what they've learned from
the AR profit boarding right here. And
this is pretty much an infinite scroll
of like just cool stuff that people have
learned from the group. So, that's
number one awesome to see, but number
two, it shows you that this is a real
group full of real people who are
getting awesome results, which is what
we love, right? So feel free to get that
link in the comments description or just
go to the apiprofitbom.com
to get